ya recibí un montón de solicitudes para
hacer algunos vídeos acerca de
inversiones entonces creo que es buena
idea hacer eso hacer algunos vídeos
acerca de inversiones e inversiones la
forma en la que voy a proceder es la
siguiente en los siguientes vídeos les
voy a dar el vocabulario o al menos una
forma de cómo se le hace para pensar en
inversiones cuáles son los términos
cuales son los coeficientes cuando
tienen sentido cuando no tienen sentido
porque aplican y por qué no aplican
después vamos a utilizar esas
herramientas para ver algunas compañías
en particular y mi objetivo pues no es
tanto como que decirte compra compra
compra vende vende vende como en algunos
canales financieros porque realmente no
creo que esa sea una buena forma de
proceder pero lo que sí voy a hacer y es
darte las herramientas para que llegues
a las conclusiones por ti mismo o sea
tal vez en los vídeos y lleguemos a
algunas conclusiones pero no quiero ser
muy contundente con ellas porque no
quiero que por mi culpa pierdas todo lo
que tienes ahorrado en tu afore entonces
la primera cosa que creo que podría
decirse que me molesta un poquito es por
ejemplo voy a una reunión familiar y
llega no se llega a mi tío no llega a mi
tía y me dice oye acabo de hacer un
negocio
compre acciones de sabritas estaban
super baratas y estaban nada más
digamos un peso es una acción super
barata y aquí implícitamente están
asumiendo que una acción de 10 pesos
sería cara pero a ver creo que es algo
muy obvio para ti pero déjame déjame
escribirlo entonces precio por acción
precio
acción ok entonces cuando alguien me
dice que una acción pues de un peso es
barata está diciendo que es un número
bajo verdad implícitamente en
comparación con 12 10 pesos vamos a
llamarle aquí valor
valor y aka valor ver y creo que esto es
algo muy obvio para alguien bueno espero
verdad alguien que haya pasado un poco
de tiempo aprendiendo acerca de de
inversiones que quiere decir el valor de
una acción pero créeme que te
sorprenderías por la cantidad de
doctores e ingenieros en mi familia que
se dejan llevar únicamente por el precio
entonces creo que es un buen lugar para
empezar ya sabes para aclarar cualquier
confusión entonces mi pregunta para ti
es realmente algo que vale un peso es
mucho más barato comparado con algo que
vale diez pesos pues todos los días sí o
sea por ejemplo si compra una manzana
por un peso es más barato que una
manzana de 10 pesos verdad si cualquier
bien pero lo que hace aquí diferencia
verdad el chiste consiste en que una
acción simplemente es una acción no
representa toda la compañía simplemente
es una fracción de la compañía
simplemente es una acción y no todas las
compañías tienen la misma cantidad de
acciones por ejemplo haber dejado de
poner que tengo una compañía qué
digamos que se ve algo así es que creo
que es un buen momento para introducir
la hoja de balance pero supongamos que
tenemos una compañía porque hacer esto
por en todas las discusiones entonces
tenemos una compañía cuyo activo vale
digamos un millón un millón de pesos
ok eso de ahí es el activo ya sabe su
edificio sus empleados y su marca todo
eso vale un millón de pesos y ahora por
el momento vamos a decir que no tiene
nada de deuda después voy a introducir
deuda y esta es otra variable importante
mucha gente olvida haber la deuda cuando
ve el valor de una acción simplemente se
fijan en el capital o en la
capitalización de mercado no te
preocupes en el transcurso de los vídeos
nos acostumbraremos a los términos pero
por el momento supongamos que su activo
vale un millón que no tiene pasivo y
entonces todo el activo pues es el
capital verdad como no tiene deuda todo
esto de acá es capital algunas veces se
llama el capital de los accionistas el
capital es todo aquello que le pertenece
a las personas que son los dueños de la
compañía en este caso como nunca
pidieron prestado esto del activo verdad
entonces los dueños de la compañía son
dueños de todo esto
si crees claro que estoy aquí vale un
millón de pesos ahora podríamos tener
este otro escenario déjame más bien
copiar este mismo escenario
hasta entonces aquí tenemos dos
compañías así equivalentes completamente
equivalentes pero esta compañía de acá
pudo haber decidido pues no se pudo
haber decidido tener nada más 10
acciones déjame dibujarlas una dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve y
diez
creo que hay son diez bueno al menos
desde mi intención que tengan diez
acciones entonces cuál es el valor por
acción bueno cada acción en este caso
otra vez si crees que este activo vale
un millón de pesos verdad entonces va a
ser un millón a ver el capital también
sería un millón verdad porque no hay
nada de deuda entonces todo el activo
pues se está haciendo desde los dueños
de la compañía entonces cada acción
valdría un millón entre días que es
igual a cien mil pesos
obviamente no vas a ver acciones por ahí
que valgan cien mil pesos en el mercado
bueno al menos no en la mayoría de los
casos porque pues 100 mil es súper caro
verdad este es más bien como un ejemplo
artificial que está de aquí pues no se
podría tener más bien un millón de
acciones en cuyo caso valdría un peso
pero bueno este es un caso con diez
acciones vamos
esta compañía dice no concepto de que
está muy loco si en mí por acción no nos
conviene no no vamos a lograr vender
tantas acciones entonces vamos a
dividirlo en un millón de acciones
entonces estoy acá tienen tiene un
millón de acciones
entonces en esta situación cuánto vale
la compañía o más bien en cuánto vale
cada acción entonces es un millón
dividido entre la cantidad de acciones
que es un peso nada más ok entonces
regresando a esta idea en la que ya
sabes llega un miembro de mi familia y
me dice mira está compañía está súper
barata comparada con esta de por acá
más aún supongamos que por alguna razón
no sea mejor no muchas personas pueden
comprar esta acción y pues es muy cara
entonces pues para meter para meter
dinero aquí hay que pagar muchos
pongamos que el precio está más barato
que se compra y se vende a 50 mil el
precio de mercado es de 50 mil pesos ok
recuerda los activos son idénticos
entonces bueno obviamente no hay dos
compañías con un activo idéntico verdad
pero supongamos que lo son supongamos
que en ambos casos el activo de esta y
de esta compañía valen exactamente lo
mismo bueno entonces acá los
inversionistas están valorando esta
compañía a un peso por un millón de
acciones o sea este activo lo están
valorando en un millón pero acá el
inversionista está diciendo ok estoy
dispuesto a pagar 50 mil pesos
acción y únicamente hay distracciones
entonces están evaluando los activos en
500.000 y claro este es el valor de
mercado verdad después vamos a hablar un
poco más de la diferencia entre valor de
mercado y valor del libro el valor de
mercado pues más o menos es cuántos dice
el mercado que vale el activo el valor
en libro es cuánto dicen los contadores
que vale el activo claro hay toda una
metodología para hacer la contabilidad
acerca de estas cosas pero bueno este es
el valor del mercado del activo y bueno
ya te dije que estos activos son
idénticos verdad hacen exactamente la
misma cantidad de ganancias con el mismo
riesgo entonces en esta situación estás
pagando 500 mil por la misma cantidad de
activos y acá estás pagando un millón o
sea no sé realmente cuánto vale cada
acción pero en total lo está evaluando
en esta cantidad entonces la persona que
dice que
un peso acá es barato comparado con
50.000 y bueno incluso podría decir mira
es la misma compañía acá es un peso de
50 mil estar acá debe ser barata bueno
esa para esa persona está completamente
mal está totalmente en dirección opuesta
porque porque estás pagando más por esta
compañía estás pagando un peso por una
millonésima parte de acá y acá estás
pagando 50 mil por una décima parte de
la compañía entonces la de la izquierda
de hecho es un mejor negocio entonces en
general cuando estás intentando
determinar el precio relativo de una
compañía y bueno después vamos a hablar
un poco más de coeficiente es cómo saber
si algo es inherentemente barato
comparado con sus ganancias o con lo que
podría ganar o crecimiento lo que sea
pero cuando la primer cosa es que no
puedes simplemente ver el precio el
precio casi casi es un número sin
significado claro importa un poquito
wayne ciertas transacciones de
compra-venta para algunos fondos
institucionales por ejemplo que no
comprarían acciones debajo de un peso
así cuando hay acciones que están
valuadas en centavos eso hace mucha
fricción cne o sea cuando hay acciones
valuadas en centavos porque osea si
tienes una acción de 10 pesos podría
digamos a 10 pesos con un centavo o
podría bajar a 9 pesos con 99 centavos
simplemente es un que es con una
variación de punto 1 por ciento verdad
pero si tenemos una acción que está
evaluada en menos de un peso digamos en
5 centavos entonces se puede mover nada
más hacia arriba un centavo verdad
aunque antes no se déjame decir a ver
punto 05 poder ser punto 06 o podría
bajar podría bajar a punto 04 pero qué
sucede en este caso en este caso en
cualquier dirección tenemos una
variación de 20 por ciento comparada con
esta de acá que es una milésima parte de
variación a 1.1 por ciento por eso no
podría importar el precio verdad acá
arriba estas fricciones de compraventa
pues podrían ser un poco incómodas dar
unas variaciones de 20% es muy grande
después vamos a hablar de liquidez ya
otras cosas pero ellas cuando el precio
empieza a importar por ejemplo otra otra
situación es un precio muy grande como
acá verdad 100 mil pesos es súper caro
entonces algo con la gente no lo compra
pero hay pocas situaciones de ese estilo
inherentemente así en el fondo cuando
estás hablando de valor
tienes que hacer es tomar el precio por
acción y multiplicarlo por la cantidad
de acciones por la cantidad de acciones
entonces este estos valores
déjame trazar una línea para dividir y
borrar un poco para regresar a lo que
estaba hablando entonces quiero borrar
esto de acá creo que ahí está verdad
entonces en este ejemplo no déjame
también borrarlo de arriba a la derecha
para tener espacio
ok entonces lo que tengo que borrar esto
de acá verdad bueno muy bien ahora sí ya
que está borrado regresamos al ejemplo
en este ejemplo es importante escribir
la cantidad de acciones que tienes
entonces aquí le voy a poner cantidad
podemos checar esto en yahoo finanzas
algo lo hagamos en el futuro vamos a ver
algunos ejemplos en concreto para hacer
las métricas pero bueno este es un buen
lugar para empezar entonces vamos a ver
no sé digamos que tiene 10 millones de
acciones y que acá abajo tiene 500 mil
si vamos a poner que tiene 500.000
acciones ok entonces lo que hay que
hacer es multiplicar estos dos números
para determinar cuál es el valor de
mercado o bien la capitalización de
mercado de la compañía
eso es una palabrota verdad déjame
escribirla
cuál es la capitalización
capitalización de mercado mercado
ok capitalización de mercado entonces
esencialmente consiste en cuánto dice el
mercado que vale el capital de la
compañía en este caso como no tenemos
deuda entonces el mercado nos está dando
implícitamente el valor del activo
entonces hay que hacer esta
multiplicación es 1 por 10 es un peso
por 10 millones 1 por 10 millones es 10
millones de pesos verdad eso es lo que
vale el capital de la compañía acá abajo
es 10 pesos por acción x 500 mil
acciones 10 por 500 mil es 5 millones de
pesos ok eso de ahí es la capitalización
de mercado de la compañía es lo que la
gente dice que la compañía nos vale muy
bien
creo que se me está acabando el tiempo
verdad en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
hablar un poco acerca de cómo le hace la
gente para determinar cuánto vale algo
eso puede llevar a discusiones super
profundas verdad pero bueno al menos
vamos a darnos un chapuzón hasta pronto